tiger king star jeff johnson dead by
suicide at the age of 58.
everybody that had been involved all got
drugged into court e.t has obtained the
report from the oklahoma city police
department inside jeff's wife says he
shot himself in the head with a glock 45
while they were having an argument in
the garage
the report states jeff was alive when
paramedics arrived on scene and was then
transported to the university of
oklahoma medical center where he was
pronounced dead it's also confirmed that
jeff had no history of mental health
issues jeff who was billed as a former
reptile dealer appeared on tiger king's
first season in episode 4 where he
discussed joe exotic losing his zoo the
docu-series captivated the nation at the
beginning of the coronavirus pandemic
back in march of 2020. tiger king
follows joe exotic whose real name is
joseph maldonado passage and his
struggles to maintain his big cat zoo in
oklahoma
an inmate at the grady county jail
[Music]
me and carol
made money off of each other we became
popular off of each other johnson is the
second tiger king death in recent months
after zookeeper eric cowie who worked
with joe exotic died on september 3rd
from acute and chronic alcohol use the
second installment of tiger king
premiered on netflix on november 17th
carol baskin declined to participate in
the latest season but when e.t spoke
with her ahead of its release she
revealed if she planned on tuning in
will you watch it
i'll have to because you know that
they're going to trash talk me again
you